si usted tiene visión borrosa u otras
complicaciones debido a una catarata en
el lente del ojo cristalino el médico
puede recomendarle una cirugía para
remover dicha catarata
el cristalino es un disco transparente
que recibe la luz a través de la pupila
y la enfoca sobre la retina para
ayudarle a producir una imagen clara el
cristalino está compuesto principalmente
de agua y proteínas a medida que
envejecemos estas proteínas pueden
comenzar a aglutinarse y opacan el
cristalino a esta opacidad se le llama
catarata una catarata puede bloquear el
ingreso de la luz a los ojos y provocar
visión borrosa
antes de la cirugía se le aplicarán unas
gotas para dilatar las pupilas y se
lavará el área alrededor del ojo
en la mayoría de los casos se le
inyectará un anestésico local alrededor
o detrás del ojo
también le pueden aplicar un sedante
para ayudarlo a relajarse
la mayoría de las cirugías de catarata
duran menos de una hora
el método más común para la extracción
de las cataratas es la
facoemulsificación
en este procedimiento el cirujano
mirando a través de un microscopio
quirúrgico realiza una pequeña incisión
a un lado de la córnea
el cirujano hace una abertura a través
de la cápsula del cristalino y mediante
el uso de una sonda de ultrasonido rompe
el cristalino opaco en pequeños
fragmentos acto seguido el cirujano
aspira a estos fragmentos a través de la
incisión
luego se inserta un lente intraocular
artificial
los lentes intraoculares están hechos de
plástico silicona o compuestos acrílicos
y permanecerán colocados dentro del ojo
por el resto de su vida
generalmente no se requieren puntos
debido a que la incisión es muy pequeña
a menudo la visión mejora notablemente
inmediatamente después de la cirugía
después de la cirugía se coloca un
parche sobre el ojo y usted estará en
observación durante un corto periodo de
tiempo para asegurarse de que no se
presenten problemas como el sangrado la
cirugía de catarata se realiza de forma
ambulatoria así que probablemente usted
se irá a casa el mismo día debido a que
la exposición a la luz brillante puede
ser incómoda al principio usted debe
hacer los arreglos para que alguien lo
lleve a casa